وأصيبت فتاة بنوبة ذعر وفقدت الوعي،
هذه ممرضة الرعاية الحرجة كريستين
جيرونيمو من ولاية كونيتيكت في لحظة
انتشرت الآن على نطاق واسع، كان لدينا كبار السن، وكان لدينا
أطفال، وكان لدينا نساء حوامل، ولم
يكن لدينا حتى ماء، ولم تمر حتى الماء الذي
رأته  أتحدث هنا نيابة عن مجموعة من
الركاب عند شباك التذاكر التابع لشركة يونايتد
في مطار نيوارك ليبرتي الدولي
بعد أن تأخرت رحلتهم ثم
ألغيت في الساعة الواحدة صباحًا، كان الجو
حارًا جدًا وكان من الصعب التنفس، لقد
حوصرنا على تلك الطائرة لمدة سبع ساعات،
يجب أن يكون هناك  تحقيق فيدرالي،
أنا مندهش من أن شخصًا ما لم يمت،
كانت إيرونيمو متوجهة إلى روما في 3 يوليو
مع عائلتها ومئات آخرين،
وبعد وقت قصير من جلوسها على متن
الطائرة، بدأت الأمور تسوء،
لاحظنا أن مكيف الهواء أصبح ساخنًا.
لم تكن الطائرة تعمل،
وتوجهت عائدة إلى البوابات،
فقفز الميكانيكيون عليها وبدا أن المشاكل قد تم
حلها حتى بدأت ترتفع درجة حرارتها مرة أخرى،
يقول أيرونيمو، وذلك عندما
قال القبطان إن الطائرة كانت عائدة إلى
البوابة وسينزلون منها.
استغرقت العملية أكثر من ثلاث ساعات،
كان الناس يخلعون قمصانهم وكانت
النساء يرتدين حمالات الصدر الرياضية، وكان الجو
حارًا جدًا وأصبح
لا يطاق ولم تكن هناك تهوية، وكانت أكبر صدمة
لجيرونيمو خلال الساعات السبع، لم يتم
تقديم أي شيء على الإطلاق، حتى أن أحدًا لم يعرض عليه
الماء.  "هل تريد مني أن أفعل ذلك هو
الاقتباس الدقيق الذي حصلت عليه من إحدى
المضيفات، تقول جيرونيمو إنها شاهدت
كبار السن يتعرقون، وكان طفلًا يبكي
وفتاة صغيرة فقدت
الوعي تقريبًا، ولا بد أنها أصيبت بنوبة ذعر وكانت
تتقيأ وزارة الخارجية الأمريكية".
تقول وزارة النقل إن شركات الطيران يجب أن
تزود الركاب بالطعام والماء في موعد
لا يتجاوز ساعتين بعد
بدء تأخير المدرج، وحتى سياسة يونايتد
تدعي أنها ستوفر الغذاء الكافي
والمياه الصالحة للشرب في موعد لا يتجاوز
ساعتين بعد بدء
تأخير المدرج ما لم يكن الطيار في
تقرر القيادة أن اعتبارات السلامة أو الأمن
تحول دون مثل هذه الخدمة، فماذا
حدث لو كان والدا الرئيس التنفيذي سكوت كيربي
على متن تلك الطائرة، هل كان
سيفعل شيئًا ترك الركاب في
المطار بدون أماكن إقامة أو
طعام، وفي
النهاية وجدت عائلتها غرفًا وتم إلغاء الرحلة؟  قادرة على
حجز رحلات جوية جديدة لليوم التالي على
نفقتها الخاصة والتي يقول جيرونيمو إنها
أضافت ما يصل إلى أربعة آلاف دولار من عرض
يونايتد، وكانت قسائم التعويض
أربعمائة دولار، ولديها الآن
رسالة إلى الرئيس التنفيذي لشركة يونايتد وأعتقد أنه
بحاجة إلى معرفة كيف سيسير الأمر
لتعويضنا جميعًا لأنها كانت
تجربة مروعة جدًا